okay first of all why only six episodes
like how could you
yeah oh gosh that's the best compliment
i've ever heard thanks so much so mad
thanks so much
why
a while at
oh i think you know yeah he wanted to
keep it keep the good stuff you know
concentrated yeah
yeah
fast quick you know fun ride yeah
what was it about this story that you
not only wanted to be ep and make this
series but you wanted to play pam
um
that was you know fascinating
look at human behavior yeah
um i was now i found this case so
compelling so curious about how it might
be possible that these things occurred
yeah um so yeah that'd be interesting to
explore and it was
yeah
how much of a true prime fan are you
because i know you're a big fan but like
what are we talking here
well i mean
you know
there's a lot of traffic and i'm saying
so
that was really helpful for a fight yes
oh all the podcasts and stuff yeah yes
um what was the reaction from your
immediate circle on your transformation
because
holy smokes
you were incredible
well um
well thanks i feel like uh cheating to
take a compliment from you on that
because i just kind of sat there and it
kind of happened all around me
um yeah i know it's it was i was amazed
yeah watching all these talented artists
do what they do you know i knew very
little about you know the process how
they're made or how to work with them
yeah i didn't know that that's a skill
set i didn't have
at all
so
yeah that was
an exciting experience to do something
new you know yeah did you get a chance
to talk to pam and like preparing for
this role no no you're like hell no no
there was a yeah just uh it seemed like
uh
there were uh there's a lot of
information on the public record yeah
there's um she wanted on public record
her interviews
her testimony and job
and um lots of conversations with people
who are involved in the case people who
know um the people involved so that
seemed like a really good place to start
yeah
and lastly are you going to attend the
oscars because you always do you always
look fantastic that's really kind are
you going i don't think so no no i don't
think so there's no no plans no i didn't
make a phone this year but you can still
go and wow us with the fashion oh that's
really fun
no i think somebody else has celebrated
this year okay yeah a lot of yeah great
stuff to celebrate this year too awesome
awesome thank you you're so incredible
it was great to meet you nice to meet
you thank you thank you